hey guys it's Inka and I'm gonna be
eating black foods for 24 hours so we're
doing this again I've done purple color
yellow color and this time because of
popular demand I am doing black foods
again this is a frame that has been done
by a lot of youtubers like Kirsten and
saffron just like before we are not
gonna do anything that's artificially
colored everything I eat must be
naturally black I know black isn't
exactly the most appetizing color but I
think I'll be able to find some things
that might change your mind it's gonna
take me a while to source these black
foods I'm gonna go to multiple grocery
stores and from there I'll plan my meals
around that I'm excited let's do this
around the store
Emily
here kind of expensive so maybe not and
the topic sentence
dark soy sauce medium dark soy sauce
black fungus found two kinds of black
rice
see you'd really put it black sesame
black bean garlic sauce on these super
cute parent ice cream birds but I think
they're they have a lot of white so I
won't be able to do it preserve duck
eggs
I really wasn't expecting to find us
here but we have some black chickens so
I'm excited look at this in morning so
it is now breakfast time I have my black
shirt on I only have two things in mind
for breakfast I'm gonna show you guys
right now I have blackberries and then I
also have black soy beans I am going to
turn this into soy milk using my soy
milk maker this is the soy beans after
they're soaked so this has been soaking
overnight this is my soy milk maker I
use it a lot because I love soy milk the
process is actually super fast what is
essentially doing is just heating it up
grinding it up about maybe half an hour
later we're gonna have soy milk this is
now gone what color is it oh it's a
great color
I guess the beans turn out more gray in
the end I am going to grab my sesame
powder and breakfast is done I kept it
super simple really just the
blackberries and the soy milk here's the
black sesame soy milk it's definitely a
lot lighter than you would think after
the process it went from this to a much
lighter color black sesame also helped a
little bit with that being said I think
this is a pretty typical breakfast for
me my fries are always good going to
give this a try it's smells super black
sesame fish yeah that's good the black
sesame definitely adds like a nutty
texture I am pretty pleased I think that
these starting off pretty well I'm gonna
finish this up and catch you guys at the
office it's now lunch time and I'm back
here in the tasty kitchen figured I
would make just a four ingredient pasta
dish I found a couple of items that I
think we can throw together and make it
work gonna show you guys what I have
black squid ink pasta the Hawaiian black
salt which I have never seen before
black truffle sauce totally bought the
black truffle sauce because I don't
think we have enough in our budget to
actually buy real truffles and then we
have black garlic comes in like this
Brown shape and then when you peel it
off there's that black garlic bulb
inside
looks like this it really is just aged
garlic the texture of it is really
sticky I've never had this before this
is gonna be really interesting
the flavor is supposed to be more mild
than garlic but it smells stronger so
I'm just gonna really quickly chop up
the black garlic right now got the water
boiling here let's get to work oh it's
so squishy this is so interesting it
looks like candy almost I don't know
what that means but I hope it's still
gonna taste good salt this quickly
pasta is now done we're now going to put
the garlic in here we go I don't want to
burn it getting smoky it smells good
though it looks a little bit like
mushrooms at this point the smell of it
is like super fragrant it's a really
nice smell it's looking super dark so
that's cool I'm gonna add the truffle
sauce which smells so good lastly just a
sprinkle of salt it's time for the grand
reveal
it's super dark let me try to find a
garlic bit that's what the black garlic
looks like now I'm gonna add some black
pepper on there okay so this is my black
coffee which is normally how I drink
coffee actually let's give this a taste
black I know doesn't really look that
appetizing usually but I have high hopes
hmm oh I just got a huge bite of the
black garlic mm-hmm oh the black garlic
is it's super chewy you think of like a
gummy candy the squid ink pasta is good
it's really just like normal pasta I
don't normally eat black truffle I'm not
that bougie the black truffle sauce is
nice
I feel like an elevated mushroom sauce
overall not bad for a plate of complete
darkness
this is definitely a good way to balance
it out my grandpa is gonna make my
tongue black nope
not yet as per usual I'm gonna finish
this up and then I'll see you guys for
the next meal I hope it just told me
that he left some cookies on my desk
that I should be able to eat on this
challenge so I'm going back to my desk
[Music]
smells really good this is so dark it's
an actual black cookie he did say that
this is made from 100% cocoa so I think
that means I could eat it this is
actually really good it's like kind of
bittersweet
more so than like a normal chocolate
cookie that's my snack for the day
so it's after work I found a bubble tea
place on Instagram that sells is really
cool looking black colored boba drink so
I'm gonna go there with a couple of
friends and check it out I'm here with
my friends I have friends this is what
the drink looks like there's boba grass
jelly and I think this is like a cocoa
boom there's a lot of white in here so
I'm gonna try and mix it together and
see if it's gonna turn more black
because it didn't do anything and I
still drink this yeah yeah I mean that's
fine good very interesting tastes like
chocolate milk if you add a little bit
of grass jelly to it Oriol this does
taste like Oreo
it's like Oreo and a drink so for dinner
we have a bunch of things black rice and
then there's wild rice and I already
cooked it in my rice cooker as you guys
can see Oh woody or mushroom which ends
up after you soak it looking like this
black bean garlic sauce the dark soy
sauce this is the century-old egg that a
lot of people are scared of and then we
also have seaweed black fish roll I
honestly wasn't expecting to find this
at all but kind of like what happened
with the truffle can't exactly afford
caviar so this is a good substitute I'm
also realizing there's a lot of really
expensive stuff that's black huh well
here's our caviar for the night and then
I also have chicken soup cooking in the
background which my room a started for
me earlier because it takes two and a
half hours just based on what we have
I'm thinking I'll probably end up making
something like a sushi roll I don't
really want to call it sushi because
it's really just me trying to mesh all
the ingredients together and we'll have
chicken soup on the side I'm just
cutting up the whittier my shoes even
though they're called mushroom they're
more like you know jelly and super
rubbery and slippery when you bite into
it it's more like a crunchy chewy
texture this is what the preserved egg
looks like it smells super pungent and I
think they like challenged people to eat
this like on Survivor or something but
it's really not that scary I grew up
eating this in like rice porridge congee
we call it it does smell very strong
though I will say it
but don't let that keep you away this is
what it looks like on the inside super
black right now the only thing about
cooking back food is that you don't know
like what if I actually burnt it I have
rice it turned out fluffier than I had
expected - I have my preserved duck egg
and wood ear mushroom and then I have my
tobiko
let's try this I'm going to now roll
this up to my best to the best of my
abilities my makeshift sushi mat so I
have my sushi roll I'm just gonna cut it
now and plate it and then it will be
done alright guys dinner is served
and here's the chicken okay
the food is literally so dark that the
camera doesn't know where it is boom I
put the black tobiko on top of it but
this is just a smear of like it's soy
sauce thicker soy sauce like I tried to
make it fancier because it looks like
caviar even though it's not caviar you
guys have to see this look at this
drumstick that's all natural you guys my
roommate made this into a soup but I
took out the soup because the soup is
brown in Taiwan they make chicken soup
with black chicken sometimes it's really
good for your body that's what my mom
told me growing up so I believe it I
also have my soy milk from earlier
that's what it looks like looks
appetizing I'm gonna try the one with
the fish roll because it looks like
fancy sushi
there's like crunchy bits in there both
from the wood ear mushroom and the fish
world officials salty it adds a lot of
flavor the black bean garlic sauce is
really coming through this one's really
good
it really isn't as terrifying as it
looks I try the chicken it's super
tender it's super interesting to look
the meat is like gray look at this the
skin is completely black meat is super
tender is literally falling off it has
also been cooking for like three hours
oh it's super clean with the soy sauce
Wow I think out of like all the one
color challenges I've done this might be
my favorite meal so far guys this is so
great I'm super satisfied let me know
what color you guys think I should do
next leave a comment below otherwise see
you guys next time
[Music]